I love numbers.
I love how straightforward and direct they are.
I love how one plus one is always equals to two,
and how two plus two, without a doubt, equals to four.
And so when it was time for us to decide
what we wanted to do in university,
I knew for sure that I wanted to work with numbers.
So you can imagine my joy when I heard
about something called actuarial science.
For those of you who do not know what that is,
it's this really amazing course
that has you spending your days doing things
like calculus and probability and statistics.
It's what insurance companies use to know
the mortality rates, hence tell you
how much premium you need to pay.
It's what governments use to know what areas to invest.
I mean, who wouldn't want to spend
the rest of their lives doing that?
But just before I went to university,
I was diagnosed with epilepsy.
And the doctor told me that I had to make sure
I did three things.
Ate well, slept well, and never missed my medication.
So under the doctor's advice,
I enrolled to do actuarial science
at the University of Nairobi.
A few years into it, I was lucky enough
to get an internship at an insurance company.
I remember my first day there.
I had a mismatched suit, but it was a suit nevertheless.
And the director's assistant was assigned
to show me around.
And since we were almost the same age,
we quickly clicked and made it a routine
to come very early in the morning
just to share our dreams and ambitions.
A few weeks into the job,
the company got a really big business deal,
which meant all of us had to chip in.
And we spent one Friday afternoon
learning how to use this new fancy photocopying machine.
On Saturday morning when reported for duty,
I got the honorable duty of working
with a new photocopying machine.
I remember walking into the copier room
armed with a room of papers and a stack of files
that I needed to photocopy.
I opened the machine just to make sure
it had enough papers as we had been instructed
the day before.
Then I woke up in the hospital.
And the doctor told me that I have something called
photosensitive epilepsy.
This is a type that is triggered by flashing lights
and in my case, with the beam from the photocopying machine.
And since I had a known history of epilepsy,
the doctor said that there was no need for me to be admitted
and that I should go home and get some rest.
So I went home, got some rest,
and was looking forward to Monday morning
to redeem myself at the workplace.
On Monday morning, I went back to the office
and the director's assistant told me
that I had been given two weeks to get more rest.
I was really excited about this
because here I was doing my dream job
and I was working for a company that cared about my health.
And so I went home and I did some research
on this photosensitive epilepsy
so that I could make sure it never happens
in the workplace again.
And after the two weeks, I went back to work
and the director's assistant told me
that they'd given me two more weeks.
This time around, I wasn't as excited as I was before.
For some reason, deep within me,
this two plus two was not adding up to four.
And so in the evening, after work hours,
I called the director's assistant
and I asked her if she had heard anything about my case.
And after a few minutes of silence
in what was almost like a whisper,
she said to me,
Sitawa, the director said that
we cannot work with someone like you.
This meant that they couldn't work with someone
with a health condition like mine.
And after a few more moments of silence,
she said that he was thinking of telling the person
who'd introduced me to this insurance company
to break the news to me.
I can't really recall how that fun conversation ended.
I don't know if she hung up first or if I hung up first,
but I remember bursting out into tears.
And I cried because of the pain I felt
that the director of this insurance company
did not have the courage or the integrity to tell me
to my face that I didn't have a job anymore,
but he kept giving me two and two more weeks off.
But most of all, I cried because I didn't ask for this.
I just started falling down.
And so after a few days of crying,
I turned my tears into words
and moved those words to a blog.
And before I knew it,
people living with epilepsy were coming to my blog
for inspiration and information and support.
And as the numbers grew,
I started a hotline
and they were able to get prompt support from it.
And so I started writing my own blog.
I still love numbers.
I love the truth in them.
I love the fact that numbers tell us things about people.
And from the numbers I have interacted with,
I see a future where people like me living with epilepsy
increase in their workplace.
I also see a future where people working with us
know that they can work with us
and they can touch us
and they'll not get this thing that we have.
And this thing that we have
only puts us down for a little while
and after that we are able to rise up
to contribute to the wellbeing
of this amazing world that we live in.